In the first video on evolution,
I gave the example
of the peppered moth during the
Industrial Revolution in
England and how, before the
Industrial Revolution, there
were a bunch of moths: some were
dark, some were light,
some were in between.
But then once everything became
soot filled, all of a
sudden, the dark moths were less
likely to be caught by
predators and so all of the
white moths were less likely
to be able to reproduce
successfully, so the black
moth trait, or that variant,
dominated.
And then if you came a little
bit later and you saw all the
moths had turned black,
you'd say all
these moths are geniuses.
They appear to have somehow
engineered their way to stay
camouflaged.
And the point I was making
there is that, look, that
wasn't engineered or an explicit
move on the part of
the moths or the DNA, that was
just a natural byproduct of
them having some variation, and
some of that variation was
selected for.
So that example, that was pretty
simple: black or white.
But what about more complicated
things?
So, for example, here I've got a
couple of pictures of what's
commonly called the
owl butterfly.
And what's amazing here, and
it's pretty obvious, as I
probably don't have to point out
to you, is its wing looks
like half of an owl's eye.
I can almost draw a beak here
and draw another wing there
and you can imagine an owl
staring at us, right?
And here, too, I could imagine
a beak here and you would
think an owl there, too.
And so the question is how does
something this good show
up randomly, right?
I mean, you could imagine, OK,
little spots or black and
white or grey, but how does
something that looks so much
like an eye generate randomly?
Now the answer is-- well,
there's a couple of answers.
One is why does this eye
exist, or this eye-like
pattern or this owl-like
eye's pattern?
And there, the jury's
still out on that.
I read a little bit about it on
Wikipedia and all of these
images I got from Wikipedia.
In Wikipedia, they said,
look, there's two
competing theories here.
One theory is that this, even
though to us humans, the way
we see things, it looks like
an owl's eye, that this is
actually a decoy.
When some predator wants to eat
one of these things, they
go for the thing that looks
most substantive.
So instead of going for the
butterfly's body, which
doesn't look that substantive,
they go for
the big, black thing.
They say, oh, that looks like
it's protein rich and it'll be
a good meal.
So they try to snap and bite at
that, and if they bite at
that, sure, the guy's wing's
going to be clipped a little
bit and it's going to suck,
but the animal itself, the
actual butterfly, would survive,
and maybe it can
repair its swings.
I don't know the actual biology
of the owl butterfly.
That's one theory, and then the
argument against it goes,
well, no, if that was the case,
then you would want the
black spot even further back
along its-- you'd want the
spot way far away
from the body.
You'd want it back here instead
of right here, because
there's still a chance, if
something chomps at this
little black spot, that
it'll still get the
abdomen of the butterfly.
Now, the other theory as to
why this exists-- and, you
know, who knows?
Maybe it's a little
bit of both.
Maybe both of these are true.
Maybe this offers
two advantages.
The other theory, and this is
kind of the one that jumps out
at us when we see this , is,
hey, this looks like an owl.
Maybe this is to scare away the
things that are likely to
eat this dude.
And it does turn out in my
reading that there are lizards
that like to eat these type of
butterflies, and those lizards
probably don't like to be around
birds or owls because
those owls eat them, so that
might be a deterrent.
And then the other example, they
said is, look, they tend
to be eaten by this lizard
right here-- this is what
Wikipedia told me-- and that
this lizard tends to be eaten
by this frog right there, and
that the eyes of this
butterfly are not too
dissimilar to the
eyes of this frog.
And, you know, we can debate
whether or not that's the
case, and if this was the
predator we're trying to
mimic, you could make an
argument that maybe we would
have had more green on our wing,
but that's not the point
of this video.
But it's a fun discussion to
have as to what is useful
about this eye.
But let's have the question: How
did that eye come about?
And when I say that eye, I mean
the pattern on that wing.
What set of events allowed
this to happen?
Because when I described
evolution, and we know that
everything in our biological
kingdom is just a set of
proteins and then stuff that
maybe the protein-- but mainly
protein, and that protein's
all coded for by DNA.
I'm going to do future videos
on DNA, but DNA is just a
sequence of base pairs.
It's a sequence of
these molecules.
And we represent adenine,
and guanine and
cytosine and thymine.
Then maybe you have a couple of
adenines in a row and some
guanine and thymine.
I'll do a lot more on this in
the future, but the idea is
it's just coded for by this
sequence of these molecules.
How do you go from a butterfly
that has no eye to all of a
sudden an eye that goes there?
Obviously, just one change
that happens
from a random mutation.
Maybe that G turns into an A or
maybe this C and this T get
deleted so everything-- that
alone isn't going to develop
this beautiful of a pattern or
this useful of a pattern.
So how do the random
changes explain
something that's this intricate?
And this is my explanation.
And obviously, I wasn't sitting
there watching over
the thousands or millions of
years as these owl butterflies
emerged, so this is just my
theory of how natural
selection does explain this
type of phenomenon.
You have a world where in some
environment you have
butterflies, and their wings
look like-- let's say you have
some butterflies that are
generally like this.
That's their wing, and it's a
very bad drawing, but I think
you get the idea, and there's
just some general patterns.
We've seen it before.
There's variation.
And the variation does show up
from these little random
changes in DNA.
I think we can all believe
that, that most of these
changes are kind of benign.
Maybe they just set up
differently where a little
pattern will show up or a little
speck of pigment will
show up with a slightly
different color.
And we even see amongst
these owl
butterflies, there is variation.
This dude's wing is different
than that guy's wing with the
commonality that they do have
these eye-looking shapes.
And there's not just one;
there's actually multiple.
This guy has this other thing
up here that looks
interesting, and they have
multiple things, but the one
really noticeable feature is
this eye-looking thing.
So how do we go from this
to an eye-looking thing?
So the idea is you have
some variation.
One guy might look like that.
Another guy, or gal, might--
just randomly, their dot might
be something like that.
Another gal or guy-- these wings
are really badly drawn,
but you get the idea.
This is the butterfly.
This is its antenna
right there.
That's its body.
Another butterfly's patterns
might look like this, right?
And so, they're just random.
But when they go into a certain
environment for
whatever reason, maybe one of
its predators-- maybe that
theory that these are supposed
to look like eyes is true.
And so, actually, maybe
this guy just has a
random pattern here.
And so this guy-- and I'm not
saying that it's like
definitely better.
They're both going to be found
and killed by predators, but
it's all probablistic, right?
Maybe this guy has a 1% less
chance of getting a predator,
because when a predator just
looks at him out of the corner
of that eye, that little really
hazy region kind of
looks like an eye and the
predator would be better off
just not messing with it, and
they'd rather go after the
dude that looks like this.
So it's just a slight
probability.
Now, you might, say, OK,
what's 1% going to do?
But when you compound that 1%
over thousands and thousands
of generations, all of a sudden,
this trait might
dominate because he's just going
to be killed that less
frequently, 1% less
frequently.
Now, maybe this guy has a
similar trait, but his spot is
closer to the abdomen.
And here, it's a tradeoff,
because maybe some predators
get scared away by this
concentration of pigment.
And once again, I'm not saying
that we're here yet.
We're not at this very advanced,
sophisticated
pattern yet.
We're at this random
concentration of pigment that
just shows up.
So we see that people who have
this concentration of pigment
further away from their
abdomen, they do well.
But when it's too close, maybe
some predators think that
that's actually an insect and
they want to eat it, so that's
actually a bad trait.
So what happens is this guy
dominates, and so within this
population, you start having a
lot of variation, because he
starts representing--
he's more likely to
pass on these traits.
And I want to make that
point very clear.
This isn't what happens
over the course
of an animal's lifetime.
It's not like if somehow I
experience something, or at
least our current theory if I
experience something, that I
could somehow pass on that
knowledge to my child.
What it says is if my DNA just
happens to have just some
variation that happens to be
more useful or more likely for
me to survive to reproduction
and for my children to
survive, then that will start to
dominate in the population.
So then the population, you're
going to have variations
within that.
Maybe some guys, you know, it's
going to get a little bit
to look like that.
Maybe another one's going to
look a little bit like that.
Maybe it has some spots there.
You can kind of view it as the
variation as "exploring." But
I want to be very clear not to
use any active verbs here
because this is all being done
really as almost a common
sense process, where
everything changes.
The changes that are most suited
are the ones that are
going to survive more
frequently.
And then the next generation's
going to have more of that and
then you'll have variation
within that change.
And then this one might
be like that, and
maybe this is the one.
These were good compared to
that, but now when you're
competing amongst themselves,
this one is able to reproduce
1% more than this
guy or this guy.
And so this guy becomes-- and
maybe it's some combination of
all of the above, and
they mix and match.
It's a hugely complex system.
But then this guy represents
most of the population, when I
say this guy, I'm saying this
guy's genetic information, at
least as it pertains
to his wings.
And then you get variation
amongst that.
Maybe some of it, they have a
little small dot and there's
some dots around it.
Maybe it's like this.
Maybe one of them digresses and
goes back here, but then
he has trouble competing so
he gets knocked out again.
And then some other people
have it back here.
I think you get the
point that this
isn't happening overnight.
These changes can be fairly
incremental, but we're doing
it over thousands
of generations.
So when you're talking about
thousands of generations, or
even millions of generations,
even a 1% advantage can be
significant, and when you
accumulate those variations
over a large period of time,
you can get to fairly
intricate patterns like this.
So I just wanted to explain
that, because this is often
used as, sure, I can believe
the butterfly moth or I can
even maybe believe the examples
of the antibiotics
and the bacteria or the flu,
because those are kind of
real-time examples.
But how does something this
intricate show up?
And I actually want to
make a point here.
We think this is more intricate
because we can
relate to it in our
everyday lives.
But if you actually look at a
structure of a bacteria and
how it operates or what a virus
does to infiltrate an
immune system or a cell, that's
actually on a lot more
levels a lot more intricate
than a design.
In fact, the whole reason why
I'm using this as an example
is because this is a fairly
simple example as opposed to
kind of explaining the
metabolism of a certain type
of bacteria and how that might
change and how it might become
immune to penicillin
or whatever else.
But I want to make this very
clear that these very
intricate things, they don't
happen overnight.
It's not like one butterfly
was completely one uniform
hot-pink color and then all of
a sudden they have a child
whose wings looked
just like this.
No!
It happens over large periods of
time, although there might
be some little weird hormonal
change that does this, but I'm
not going to go there,
but that is possible.
But I just wanted to make this
point because I think the more
examples we see, the more it'll
kind of hit home that
this is a passive process.
We're not talking about these
things happening overnight.
And it's actually really
interesting to look at our
world around us and look at
ecosystems as they are today
and try to think really hard
about how something came to
be, what it's useful for,
why it might have
been selected for.
For example, are traits that
occur after reproduction
selected for?
Well, probably not unless they
affect the reproduction of the
next cycle.
For example, you might say,
oh, well, the trait to be
nurturing after your
reproductive years, that's
after reproductive years.
No, but it helps your
offspring reproduce.
But we already see a lot of
diseases, especially once we
get beyond our reproductive and
our child-rearing years.
So once we get into our fifties
and sixties, the
incidences of diseases increases
exponentially from
when we're younger and because
they're no longer being
selected for, because it no
longer affects our ability to
reproduce, because we've
already reproduced.
We've already raised
our children so
that they could reproduce.
So the only thing that happens
at that point is now not being
selected for.
So anyway, hopefully, this video
will give you a little
bit more nuance on evolution,
and I want to do a couple of
videos like this, because I
really want to make it clear
that it's not making some wild
claim that all of a sudden
this appears spontaneously, that
it really is a thing that
happens over millennia and
eons and very gradually.